the pressure is on Congress to do
something about guns and school safety
after its ten-day vacation one of the
first options tougher background checks
but the calendar as always is chock-full
in Congress chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel fills us in
from Capitol Hill tonight President
Trump says he wants action on gun
control the president is planning a
meeting for Wednesday with bipartisan
members of Congress now much of the
focus has shifted to a Senate measure
from Texas Republican John Cornyn and
Connecticut Democrat Chris Murphy to
tighten up the criminal background check
system it would keep those with serious
criminal records or severe mental
illness from buying firearms House
Republican leaders are signaling they
want to see what the Senate is capable
of passing first but predict Congress
will act I believe so we have already
taken some action last year but I think
we're going to look more and you're
gonna see more legislation the
background checks measure which passed
the house late last year was attached to
a concealed carry provision New Jersey
Republican congressman Leonard Lance has
written speaker Paul Ryan asking him to
bring up just the background check
aspect today the House Majority Whip a
victim of gun violence focused more on
mistakes made leading up to the parkland
attack why did those breakdowns occur
and then let's focus more on addressing
these problems in mental health that
we've started to deal with in Congress
let's close loopholes let's figure out
what went wrong with government before
people start talking about taking away
the rights of law-abiding citizens
there's also a looming deadline one week
from today affecting the so-called
dreamers as a vet they've absent some
Court decision continuing court
protection 1000 of these young people a
day will be subject to deportation will
be unable to continue to legally work in
America they include 900 of them who
have volunteered to serve in our
military today after the Supreme Court
rejected the Trump administration's
request to immediately decide whether
ending daca could be enforced President
Trump noted the program is working its
way through the courts and made a
broader point to the nation's governor's
we have to get immigration laws that
allow us to do what we have to be able
to do they are so soft no country in the
world has immigration laws so soft like
we do lawmakers are also expected to
work on an on
this major spending bill facing a March
23rd deadline that means Congress has
four weeks to work at a major bill to
fund the government through the end of
the fiscal year and this is expected to
be a very short week with the Reverend
Billy Graham due to lie and honor in the
Capitol Rotunda on Wednesday and
Thursday
Brett my commander a live in Capitol
Hill Mike thanks